[Music]
welcome so Nelly and I are going to be
spending the next 20 minutes or so
talking through some key elements of how
to secure your Cloud infrastructure and
by that we mean your network your data
and your compute and how to do it the
Google way so what do we mean by that
the the Google way so Google secures
some of the largest web apps and
services on Earth we've learned a few
things along the way we applied our
learnings to enable some infrastructure
security for you some that we've sort of
built by default for you and and other
controls that we've made available to
you optionally
today we're going to share about some of
those security controls and how they
work without compromising performance
and that's what we mean by the Google
way
so we're going to cover the topics in
this order I'll cover networking and
then Nellie's going to cover data and
compute
Google Cloud offers a robust set of
security tools that help you secure your
Cloud infrastructure so first at the
internet Edge we provide this family of
load balancers and cdns for availability
and scalability and performance
and then built in right along that stack
are several security tools for Access
Control and for privacy and for
Authentication
to these we add tools with deeper
context and specialized layer 7 threat
understanding for things like apis fraud
from Bots and secure application access
and then inside your Cloud environment
we have fully distributed set of Access
Control capabilities for both workloads
and for our cloud services and when I
say cloud services here I mean things
like bigquery and storage and Cloud run
and then we provide a full complement
of network level telemetry
so taking it a step further we have
industry leading Advanced threat
detection capability
but if raw packets are what you want we
provide full packet Inspection Services
with our packet mirroring capability and
that can be sent to a number of
different third-party tools that you can
find in our Marketplace
all the alerts in the Telemetry from
these products are integrated into our
threat hunting alert management
and unified security systems
plus we also integrate with third-party
Sim and Source systems
of those we're going to focus in on
three product areas today Cloud firewall
Cloud IDs
and Cloud armor
so let's start with Cloud firewall we
are announcing some significant
enhancements and expansions to our Cloud
firewall offering
to set the context Google Cloud firewall
helps you achieve a zero trust posture
via a cloud native fully distributed
firewall service with Advanced
protection capabilities and granular
controls
you can even achieve
intrasubnet yeah intra subnet micro
segmentation that is applied completely
independently of the network structure
we recently launched some new
enhancements that simplify configuration
and deployment while simultaneously
helping you improve network security
posture and do so with Cloud scaling
we've introduced these capabilities in
two service tiers
Essentials and standard which is in
preview Essentials is the service tier
that forms the foundation of the cloud
firewall family
the enhancements here include a new
construct for firewall rules called
Network firewall policies we have both
Global and Regional of those
also here are secure tags objects that
can be used in your rules that are IAM
governed and also address groups
taken together these features
simultaneously help you increase policy
precision
and simplify rule creation and operation
you normally don't get those two things
together
and then
there is the new Cloud firewall standard
which as I mentioned is currently in
preview
standard introduces an expanded set of
source and destination objects for
firewall rules that are dynamic they are
built and automatically updated by
Google these are Google Cloud threat
intelligence which I'll cover in a
little bit more detail in a moment
domain name or fqdn based Dynamic
objects and geolocation based Dynamic
objects
combination
of IAM governed secure tags and
Essentials and the dynamic objects in
the new standard tier
and our existing hierarchical firewall
rules help you run a very Dynamic least
privilege
self-service environment that enforces
pinpoint policy with greater Simplicity
and decreased operational Cycles
so I just mentioned Google Cloud threat
intelligence and how it's a set of
objects for rules in firewall standard
well those same objects are also
available in Cloud armor and are going
to be available for future products
today threat intelligence includes five
types of objects
some are meant for blocking like IPS
with poor reputation and tour exit nodes
and some of them are meant for allowing
things like search engines public clouds
and Upstream providers and we'll be
adding many more types
to the threat intelligence platform over
time
So speaking of cloud armor let's go
deeper on that right now
Cloud armor is our service that protects
your websites your web services and your
apis against Advanced targeted and
automated DDOS and layer 7 attacks and
also from fraud from Bots using
recaptcha
you may leverage this Enterprise grade
ml Power Defense wherever your
application is deployed so that could be
on premise or in Colo and any of our
Google Cloud regions or actually any
public cloud provider for that matter
Cloud armor attaches to the load
balancer and provides layer 3 and 4 all
the way up to layer 7 application layer
protection and access controls to the
back end services
Cloud Armor security policies can be
configured to enforce rate limits ipgo
or ASN based access as well as
pre-configured fully customized Waf
style application protection rules this
includes our machine learning based
adaptive protection capability
now we've recently expanded
significantly the coverage that cloud
armor can provide and we've done so in
two big ways
the first is for traffic that's passing
through our TCP and SSL proxy load
balancers
so basically addressing other types of
TCP applications that might be not HTTP
or https or non-standard of those
the second is for traffic heading to our
cdns so this is Con going to include our
Cloud CDN and also our recently
announced media CDN
with these two types we significantly
expand the set of workloads in your
infrastructure for which you can now get
Edge protection from cloud armor
so when I was describing Cloud art um
just a minute ago I mentioned Planet
scale
so you see here that DDOS protection
that cloud armor customers receive
that protection is provided from
techniques that are sres and our DDOS
teams have developed over the past 20
years in the effort of protecting and
ensuring availability of our own Google
services things like search and map
due to the global nature of Google's
Network
where all of our customers are and where
all of our services run we're able to
absorb and dissipate or otherwise
mitigate attacks across various
components in our Global routing and our
load balancing infrastructure
so here's a perfect example of why this
scale is so important to you as a
customer
we recently announced that cloud armors
machine learning based adaptive
protection capability
combined with the recently gaed rate
limiting feature or instrumental in
mitigating A Massive Attack
a cloud armored customer was targeted
with a series of https connections which
peaked at
46 million requests per second
that's the largest DDOS attack of that
nature to date 76 percent larger than
the previous reported record attack
so to give you a sense of scale this is
like
all of the requests all the daily
requests to Wikipedia hitting in just 10
seconds
and the customer service remained
available throughout the attack
the cloud armor product team is actually
giving a dedicated breakout session to
this attack SEC 201 so be sure to check
it out if you want to know more about
the details there
so now let's turn our attention to Cloud
IDs this is our intrusion detection
system
Cloud IDs detects malware
spyware
command and control attacks and other
network-based threats
it's security efficacy is industry
leading
because it's built with Palo Alto
networks Technologies under the covers
being Cloud native Cloud IDs is simple
to deploy it's managed and it provides
high performance
a broad overview
of It kind of works like this so it
copies traffic from a customer's Network
as you can see with the little packet
mirror icons that are sprinkled
throughout the VPC
any traffic you want you can tell it via
the packet mirroring policy so this
could be compute engines this could be
GCE
containers and gke all the traffic
within a VPC within a subnet even vpcs
to the internet
on-prem Google services all of these
things can be expected north south east
west we have full visibility and
detection capability
so everything in the blue square is in
the middle that's what we set up and
manage for you
taking the mirror traffic it runs to the
threat detection technology and then we
let you know what we find
it's all out of band and requires zero
forwarding changes to your
infrastructure
this dramatically simplifies fulfillment
of the IDS security control requirements
that are common in several compliance
standards for example PCI
Cloud IDs also integrates with Sim and
Source Solutions enabling customers to
set up automated threat responses
to take automated actions in things like
Cloud armor Cloud firewall for example
all just based on cloud IDs detections
so it kind of works like this looker
blocks
for these applications like for example
Cloud IDs and Cloud armor
are in the marketplace you just download
them and drop them into your looker
instance the semantic layer parses the
Json messages and represents them to
looker
the dashboards are easy to export and
there's no additional cost for existing
looker users and again you can find
these blocks on
marketplace.looker.com that's it for
networking Nelly I think everybody's
eager to hear about how to better secure
data
thank you so much Gregory and our
customers as you can imagine Now
understand how to protect Network and
now let's remind everybody that we
protecting Network because customers
bring in data and workload to cloud and
to be able to protect the data first
step in the journey is to figure out
what kind of data they bring into the
cloud so the first thing is to get a
little more visibility and understand
where the right data resides we have
good tools to help in this task and it's
data loss prevention and data loss
prevention is not only preventing data
loss but it's also helping to classify
and understand our data is sensitive and
what data is not and it's also trying to
have additional tool set of capabilities
that help customers to de-risk sensitive
data what does it mean it's trying to
remove unnecessary pii data again to
this tokenization anonymization and
other techniques but it's not all let's
assume that we need to keep fully fully
Fidelity clean data you can't analyze or
tokenize it you have to have it all and
encryption is very powerful tool to
focus more on keys that encrypting this
data also encryption helping us to limit
the access to this data to encrypt your
data at rest and let me introduce a few
of them a few options so we have what we
call Cloud Key Management Services and
Cloud Key Management Services helping
you to protect your database is full of
control that you can apply to those keys
as those keys are actually created and
done and all operation encryption
operation done in software we have Cloud
hsms where all operations and key
creation is done in those Hardware
secure modules and we have additional
product in the market all of them in GA
and this product we call Cloud ekm
external key manager and it's for those
customers that want to have full
sovereignty of the keys full sovereignty
of their key management system and hsms
and want to connect their HSM system to
the cloud services so let's start with
the use case when you need to run your
VMS
so when we Define and design our
confidential Computing Story the first
step we needed to ensure that everything
you're running in this environment is
actually trustworthy and it is why we
introduce what we call shielded VMS two
years ago right now this capability
available by default on every single VM
you will start in gcp but not only VMS
but also on kubernetes on our gke on our
cloud data flow data product or any
other services around within VM and what
we're offering you protection against
malicious gas system firmware and also
malicious OS and all of these Integrity
check and all of these monitoring
information with sending to Cloud login
so you can take some actions if you will
find the situation that you'll be arms
or your systems are not running as you
expect we want to create this
confidentiality this box around your
environment and provide cryptographic
isolation among all our tenants running
in cloud and confidential VMS is
actually a normal VM you don't need to
change any line of your code you can do
lift and shift your applications from
normal VMS to confidential VMS with
simple click but it's incredibly
scalable but also from security
perspective it's one of the best
capabilities that we offered we used
special instructions on AMD CPUs to
generate the keys to encrypt memory of
your VMS but those keys is the best keys
in the world because they're random
ephemeral they generate it in the
hardware but most importantly they're
not extractable it means not us no
Google no you would be able to deal with
this keys and it's probably the best
case to have confidential gkey allow us
to create the whole entire cluster
confidential cluster as confidential
with a simple flag but again for
developers they would be able to add
special a label it's called selector
node and this selector node is something
that kubernetes
audience familiar very well and it's the
way to indicate to kubernetes engines
that this particular applications this
particular container need to be deployed
two confidential cluster
so again now we have confidential VMS we
have confidential gke for very big
analytical jobs we have confidential
data proc and confidential data proc is
including Hadoop manage Hadoop and Spark
for your clusters
but a lot of our customers asking us the
next step okay we know how to isolate
our workloads among ourselves
but how we would be able to collaborate
how we would be able to bring all of
those data sets very private data sets
together and execute workload or
applications that we agree upon without
revealing the private data to all of the
participants and it is why at next we're
introducing a new addition to
confidential Computing portfolio called
confidential space it's a cryptographic
very hardened box where all
collaborators would be able to put the
data in and run the application inside
of that with full guarantee
I said none of them would be able to
access this data or influence the
execution of their workload and it's
incredible big step toward helping
customers to collaborate securely
to summarize Gregory and I talked to you
about the security of network data and
compute and how we can help you with
protecting network data and compute in
gcp
the most importantly we also emphasize
the fact that all of those tools
incredibly easy to use performant and
scalable and it's exactly what we mean
the Google way thank you so much for
being with us bye bye
thank you
[Music]